hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent positional game to share with
you from the final round of the 2023
Tata steel Masters
on the white end in each Geary and he's
playing against Richard rapper
opening wise it's an open Sicilian
if there's one piece to pay special
attention to throughout this game it's
Geary's Queen Knight this is the MVP of
the game
we have a classical Sicilian Richter
Rouser and with G6 the dragon variation
G6 is very committal in this case with
their already being pressure on F6
black is prepared to play this position
with several weaknesses in his camp
and is also prepared to play in Gambit's
Style
I'll highlight a line where white could
potentially go after a pawn
so let's see these weaknesses
white goes ahead and captures the Knight
and after black takes away from the
center we have doubled pawns an isolated
pawn and many holes
in the position
now of these two defects it's mainly the
isolated Palm that grabs my attention
more
I could foresee the doubled pawns one
day undoubling this Pawn being exchanged
for White Center cone
but the D6 Pawn on the other hand it's
probably just either going to be around
as a half dead Pawn or just drop off at
some point
additionally by definition
and isolated upon the squared is on is a
whole and so too are the squares in
front of it D6 is the main one that has
my attention it will act as a great
springboard for several white pieces
where it can act as a springboard for
several
all right from here we have Bishop B5 a
little pressure on C6 provokes Bishop D7
some other defense is asking for trouble
now we have Bishop to C4 did you catch
that
there was a little finesse there with
Gary's King Bishop
why are we going first to B5
allowing black to develop a bishop and
then falling back to C4 wouldn't have
been better to just go to C4 straight
away
well first of all this bishop isn't
really the most brilliant developed
piece it would actually prefer to still
be on home base
from D6 it's actually interfering with
the black queen
she's no longer there
to watch over the half dead Pawn
this difference matters the location of
the Queen Bishop matters
let's see why
Bishop G7 follows
and now in comes Knight takes night
two ways to recapture
but you can't take with the pawn in this
case you would be dropping D6
black must capture with the bishop
and what does this mean it means D6 is
still
a hole
okay let's back up for a moment suppose
the bishop went to C4 straight away and
then Bishop G7 and then Knight takes
Knight no problems in this case for
black
simply recapture
this is defended and D5 is repaired no
longer a hole
okay white would not be capturing the
knight in this case but this little
finesse by the king Bishop is Paving the
way for a knight takes night move and
black will have to recapture with the
piece rather than a pawn
okay
I know at the start of the video I
pointed out the queen Knight being the
MVP but I want to at least give a little
credit to the king Bishop it does play a
supporting role
okay
from here it's Bishop G7
and in comes Knight takes Knight so
where is a line where the D6 Pawn could
fall right here
if this Knight chooses to go to B5 black
has to be prepared to play in Gambit
style the D6 Pawn is a goner
castles you know pick your favorite way
to take black will have compensation has
the bishop pair F5 is nearby the bishop
will be liberated the unopposed uh
Bishop will be liberated this is the
ideal placement for those
unopposed pieces on the longest diagonal
anyhow
in the game we have Knight takes C6
Bishop takes C6
both sides castle and a perfect spot for
the queen
opening up D1 for a rook observing
all sorts of Pawn breaks
she's really excellent on D3
from here Rook C8
Knight hops into D5
Rook E8 C3
so one day it is going to happen where
this guy sees the world F5 is in
and this structure is now round to
neutralize it
okay
from here Bishop D7 Bishop B5 and I have
a pop quiz for you
how would you react to White's last move
feel free to pause the video
okay this is a positional test
positional question
in the game it is Bishop to C6 this is a
very important moment in the game
it's important not to just allow the
exchange of the light Square Bishops
this Knight will find it much easier to
stick around on D5 and go
unchallenged
in playing Bishop C6
black is saying you take me because I
would like to repair D5
there's a fight going on over the D5
Square
throughout this game
so in this position to highlight if we
had the exchange of Bishops
and then maybe some of you may have been
thinking further with this capture well
this queen takes here
and there is no
idea to grab the B2 Pawn for example
because white already has some tricks
Rook B8 could be met with Knight F6
check and there goes the Rook
white is doing very well this is an
ideal
this is a position you'd see
in a book highlighting Superior minor
pieces
okay the White Knight is superior to the
bishop in this case
we have Bishop C6 in this game
from here Bishop C4
Geary could have repeated but he's
clearly going for more at this point we
could have had these Bishops going back
and forth but he's playing for more Rook
after E1
in comes F5
Bishop gets out of the way not really so
comfortable having the queen constantly
babysit the bishop
so she's now freed up
we have some exchanges lights able to
take with check get out of the skewer
or the pin Queen D2 Bishop E6 and where
are we training our pieces on the weak
squares D6 D5
this really does feel like
a two result position for white maybe
even dating all the way back to G6
because of these weaknesses on the D
file
from here some
flight Square for the king H3 small
improvements at this point B5 one day
looking to maybe extend the scope of the
bishop shooting for a B for advance
between F4 Rook C5
once more offering the tray to light
Square Bishops
Bishop E5 Queen E4
and now in comes some play on the king
side
with F4
G4
and we have two different Pawn breaks
it's still considered around even
at this stage
what allows for these
moves at this point I mean it's very
committal to play G4 at this stage or I
should say weakening to the king
position of course but
what what allows white to play such a
move
I believe every white piece is
Superior to blacks in this case the the
main one is probably the queen post
it's pretty nice to have the queen right
on one of those four Center squares and
for her to be stable
the night is excellent Bishop is
excellent I really do feel every white
piece is better than blacks in this case
also G4 is a is a move that's
potentially ready to question the
stability of the dark Square Bishop
okay ideally white would like to maybe
control some dark squares
okay
from here we have H6
and Bishop to D5 computers even pointing
out that white could go ahead and
initiate
The Exchange on E6
with the idea
to continue playing on the king side
with H4 looking next for G5
let me just highlight a way that black
could go wrong
if
the play continued like this white is
already winning with this idea to play
G5
kick the bishop away
and now we have this Pawn
which has been pinned and there's a way
to exploit that with Queen D4 check
followed by Queen takes Rook
white will be winning a rook
okay
anyhow
it's not all forced but it says you
could take the light Square Bishop
straight away Bishop D5
Bishop takes Bishop
Knight takes Bishop so
how to continue from here first queen is
kicked back black has slowly improved
with those last two moves it's still
around even
incomes now F5 the Knight is stable
on D5
can't really be challenged anymore
and now a new square is being opened up
for it with F5
G takes f is best is an only move
actually
some other moves such as Queen E5
light could simplify the position in the
following way
and be winning upon there are other
lines but this is one of the simpler
ones entering a rook and pawn ending
where white is up upon
and has an active Rook this is a winning
position
so
Queen E5 not a good idea
black plays in the best way
Knight F4 no recapture no time for
in-between moves either
Knight takes Queen would be hitting with
check
notice with this last capture another
positional detail
isolated Pawn on H6 what was this Pawn
doing from G6 it was guarding
H5 H5 is now a whole
and this Knight is looking to hop right
to it
gets there with Tempo hitting the queen
Knight H5 check
five options for the king
four of them are draws
black picks the wrong one
he steps up he missed an idea
there's a tactical shot here
I think this is the one that feels most
natural
you know if it's some bullet game uh you
kind of Step Up you want to stick around
controlling some Pawns
maybe you don't want to come back here
because of checks maybe the pawn Falls
and then there's a problem on F7 okay
it seems a lot more cozy it seems like
the coziest square but it's tactically
flawed
white has a winning shot here if you'd
like to pause the video and spot it feel
free to do just that
okay here we go the winning shot for
Gary
it's Queen takes D6 so
a move that was clearly overlooked there
is no Queen takes Rook because Queen
takes F5 is checkmate
so it is simply gone from here
um that was the big blunder in the game
we had King G5 as a follow-up and now
precision
the cleanest Way Forward not to take the
bishop but instead
get to the fifth rank
we're told in chess the seventh rank is
the prized rank well over time that
changes it's the fifth rank that is the
prized rank here queen king let's get
there also
after this check King G2 notice with the
Rook
is doing from D5 stopping ensuing checks
okay white is laser focused on this F5
point it will collapse
Rook takes F5 King H4
Queen G3 and this game goes no further
black resigns this was the game that
propelled Geary to victory in this
tournament
uh he overtook the the first spot
with this win
this is a very clean approach if the
game continued
Queen takes Queen Knight takes Queen
we have this main thread on H5 and there
isn't really a great way to stop that
for example Bishop here there can be
Rook takes pawn and now there's Knight
Knight F5 mate threat the only way to
stop it are moves like Rook takes Pawn
or Rook to F4
you know about now we're just losing the
exchange
and white has two pawns as well some
other line is this one right here
it's kind of funny after Rook C5 well I
could say I'm not taking you
you're taking me
B4
Rook takes Rook would be met with Knight
takes rook and then the bishop will fall
okay well after Queen G3 this game goes
no further black simply resigns so a
very nice
the game by Geary very nice positional
play in this one
let's have a look at
the tail the tape on this and we could
see
and just how smooth it was until the
very end
had five King choices five King moves
and unfortunately picked the wrong one
stepping up to G6 was the big blunder
the end of the day
97 accuracy for Geary 87
for team black
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye